[Music]
good morning Hank it's Thursday March
1st where one sixth of the way done
today's video comes in four parts part
one presents part two sophistication
part three balls part four presidential
politics yeah I said balls part one
presents Hank I want to thank you for
completing the picture book project it
really kind of made my day and it felt
like you were giving me a present I feel
like I haven't given you many presents
during the making of this video blog and
it makes me kind of sad although it
occurs to me that it's kind of a present
when I physically hurt myself because
let's face it brothers like to see that
stuff plus there's the small matter of
Christmas 2000 when I bought you a DVD
player for Christmas and you bought me
two pairs of white tube socks I feel
like you're still making up for that
anyway Hank I want you to know that I'm
definitely going to try harder to give
you presents on this video vlog in the
future part two sophistication Hank in
the first two months of our video blog
we've managed to mention most of the
major bodily functions anyway I've been
thinking that we should increase the
sophistication factor of Brotherhood 2.0
and that's why today I'm commencing a
project to read James Joyce's entire
Ulysses to you out loud 30 seconds at a
time starting now stately plump up
Mulligan came from the stair heavy
bearing a bowl of blather on which a
mirror and a razor lay crossed a yellow
dressing-gown
Unger deled was sustained gently behind
him on the mild morning air ok that's
boring part three balls Hank your video
on Monday where you had the gigantic
blob of earwax removed from your ear got
me to thinking a lot about the world's
largest balls what I'm thinking is this
if you work hard and stay committed you
could potentially accrue the world's
largest ball of earwax by the end of
2007 now of course it wouldn't just be
your earwax we would also have to get
help from our viewers they would send
you their earwax and their friends would
send you their ear wax and then finally
you would mold it together and turn it
into the world's largest ball of earwax
believe me Hank this is practical I'm a
connoisseur of the world largest balls
I've seen the world's largest ball of
twine I've seen the world's largest ball
of paint and I've seen the world's
largest ball of stamps and the world's
largest ball of earwax is just out there
waiting
be sculpted part for presidential
politics Hank I have a question for you
should Brotherhood 2.0 endorsed a
presidential candidate it's so should we
endorse a presidential candidate in the
primary I think the answers to these
questions are yes and yes and Barack
Obama what do you think the answers are
this feels kind of good actually
I'm being hanged for a day I'm being
hanged for a day I live in Montana and
rarely shower
I'm always blogging about solar power oh
I'm being Hank for a day
hey Hank something just occurred to me
did I never get you a wedding present if
so please put the word myriad in your
next video